I seem to have an issue with nail fungus. I believe it's systemic. I believe you suggested
soaking my nails in something but also are there some herbs etc. I can take. What else could I do?
I had issues for years. It's getting a little worse the last five weeks. We have a product called
Funga clear. Funga clear that you could use from a systemic standpoint. That's not going to deal with
the nails. Your blood glow to your nails is so incremental that taking something early is not
going to deal with that. You've got to go with that herbal foot soak. We don't sell that in the store
but you can look that up on Amazon herbal foot soak. I think just search that on Amazon herbal
antifungal foot soak and it's just a blend of herbs that you mix up and you soak your feet in there.
We've had really good results with it. I have had mycotoxin tested and was very high in
ocotoxin. I did your recommendation binder for a month or so until it ran out but not tested
since again. So remember different types of fungal aka mold in your body. You can have active
fungal infection. That's different than mycotoxins. So you can have a mycotoxin issue. So mycotoxins are
toxins that mold produces and it can be airborne mold. Most commonly it's going to be building
black mold from buildings. Of course, you can get it from foods to nuts and different things like
that. Even coffee can have toxins in them and they elicit mycotoxins and then you can
eat them and your absorbing mycotoxins. Mycotoxins are not living organisms. Mycotoxins are
toxins from mycotoxins from mold. So those are poisons. Those are going to be poisonous to anyone.
Living fungal reactions are different. So that's an infestation of a pathogen. So you want to
elicit an immune response and use herbals that will directly kill them. Hence you'd use our
fungal clear. If you have mycotoxins, you'd use a key later or a binder to pull those out.
Those are chemical toxins that you're pulling out and it could take years to pull those out,
especially if you have courage exposure. So you have to stay on clear talks for a while or whatever
you put you on. Living fungal infection is different. You're not going to use a key later to pull
that out. You have to kill it. So that's a pathogen that you have to kill. So you have to do things
to stimulate your immune system. It's in your feet then you have to also try to kill it directly
there. And there's a whole bunch of other techniques I'm killing it using Mr. Rita on your feet,
using the H2O2 hydrogen peroxide on your feet, doing a whole bunch of different techniques that you
can search the web on soaking your feet in different things. That can be helpful.
Running the fungal programs on the right can be helpful as well. And then there's a third which
you're not mentioning here, but since I'm talking to one of my friends, we'll talk about if there's a
third type of reaction to molds and fungi. But that's what's called an IGE reaction. So an IGE
reaction is a is more of a sensitivity reaction. So those are the people that like walk into a building
and they're like, oh my gosh, I can't stay in this building. I got a headache instantly. Why? What's
the matter? What's the matter? Oh my gosh, it's mold. There's mold in this building. Everybody else is like,
what are you talking about? I don't smell any mold in this building. Those people are not crazy.
That is they have. They could have IGE antibodies. And you could test for it if you want,
but those people don't really need to be tested for it. They know they haven't. They cannot tolerate any mold.
And so because of past exposure, they developed IGE antibodies. Well,
sometimes those just never dissipate. And they're always going to be high-persensitive
to mold. They just need to get out of the area because they literally could have an
antiflactic reaction if they stay in an environment like that. So three different things
you have to take care of it differently.